content marketing strategy by the end of
this lesson you will be able to outline
steps needed to create a content
strategy describe the importance of
various parts of a content marketing
plan including personas brand story
listening and measurement choose the
right channels that will complement your
content and prioritize and plan content
ideas around your company's biggest
opportunities content strategy versus
content marketing strategy there is a
difference between content strategy and
content marketing where content strategy
focus on the actual content content
marketing focuses on the outcome content
strategy is about a management and
creation of the media the tools you are
using the resources you have available
what are the types of content you will
be creating where content marketing is
all about the customer who are you
targeting with the content how well do
you know this person and most important
of all what is the expected business
outcome are you creating and sharing
content to build brand awareness or are
you aiming to increase revenue more
generic content marketing questions are
how it fits within your overall digital
marketing strategy what does your
content calendar look like and also by
sharing your content are you exposed to
risk in any way does your content work
for every market
content creation framework a good way to
start putting together your content
marketing strategy is by creating your
content marketing framework it enables
you to map out the required content
along the customer buying journey while
considering the impact it has on your
online presence your social media your
website and your sales between these two
areas the customer journey and your
overall digital marketing approach you
have two three types of content you need
to focus on linked content conversion
content and authority content link
content is content that drives traffic
from the internet and from your social
media to your website this is content
that is created with the goal of
attracting quality backlinks for SEO
purposes conversion content is content
that drives web visitors to the next
stage in the buying cycle through call
to actions or CTAs this is the content
that is created with the goal to
convince prospects that they should buy
from you
authority content drives web visitors to
sales through call to actions and drives
repeat traffic to your website this is
content that is created to build a
community of people that trust you and
see you as the expert in your fields
this is a useful structure to organize
your content and it keeps your focus on
the customer needs and the impact on
your overall digital marketing
objectives each type of content has
different requirements link content
needs to be high quality and often based
on research so other websites can refer
to it it's all geared towards generating
high quality backlinks to your website
which Google sees is very important for
your search ranking make this content
fail-proof repurpose it and promote it
like crazy conversion content is based
on helping the customer to go through
the buying cycle this will only work if
you understand what they need and that
your content clearly articulates that
you can help them solve their problem
but on top of that it is vital in this
stage that your content gives them the
option to move to the next stage through
very clear and compelling call to
actions and authority content is a
logical follow up from your link content
it is content that confirms you are an
expert in your fields it helps you to
build trust as long as you are truthful
transparent and show integrity and done
continuously and consistently it helps
you to deepen the relationship with your
prospects and your clients content
marketing strategy
there are various steps in developing
your content marketing strategy the
obvious thing of course is to start with
setting your objectives but additionally
you need to do a number of things
creates customer personas create
listening outposts write your brand
story develop your channel strategy
create your content marketing playbook
measure your content marketing and
establish your content marketing ROI
let's look at these elements of your
content marketing strategy in a bit more
detail customer personas a vital step in
your content marketing strategy is
creating customer personas this is a
concept that comes from the user
interface and design world in a customer
persona you look at things like
demographic characteristics like age and
gender but it is important to add to
this what their pain points are what is
their affinity with technology where do
they hang out online and what are their
interests and their hobbies once you
completed your customer personas print
them out and put them on the wall in
your office and make sure you add them
to your briefing document when you ask
your agency to create a new campaign
HubSpot has a great free tool to create
customer personas by asking a set of
questions it will put it in a format for
you that you can share and print and you
can tailor it to your own requirements
and add your own sections it includes
things like education social networks
they use preferred method of
communication tools they need
to do their job goals and objectives
challenges and how they gain knowledge
establish listening post an important
part of your content marketing strategy
is to listen to what people are talking
about online you can find out what they
think about your brand the topics they
talk about and if there are any issues
it is also great to listen online to
find good content you could share you
don't have to share just your own
content there's nothing wrong with
sharing relevant content from others
obviously when I say listening online I
mean this in the widest sense watching
videos reading articles or blogs looking
at photos or infographics or literally
listening to podcasts here are a few
tools you can use to listen feedly is a
reader app on which you can listen to
life RSS feeds
Google Alerts and talk Walker are tools
that will send you a notification for
certain terms that you have set you can
use Google Trends to find out search
trends for keywords your brand's story
the next thing you need to work out for
your content marketing strategy is your
brand story what is your mission your
vision your values what is the story of
your company your CEO remember people
want to listen and share stories when I
searched for IKEA on Google you get an
understanding of what I mean stories
about the history of the company the
founder of the company the way they work
the employees what makes them unique and
the more twists turns and uncertainties
in these stories the more people will
love them and it gets even better if you
can show them how you overcame obstacles
and bumps in the road this will increase
your credibility a good example of this
is Elon Musk from Tesla he came from a
very simple background but kept on
following his beliefs even when he was
nearly bankrupt he kept on going and
look where he is now
an important element of defining your
content marketing
strategy is understanding of what kind
of branch you are the type of branch you
are determines the type of social media
you will get with your content if you
are a basic brand you won't get many
people to talk about you let alone
comment on your social media posts
you're just fulfilling a basic needs the
only way these brands can get engagement
on social media
is to turn themselves into a funny brand
like Blendtec blenders who launched the
will it blend campaign if you are a
functional brand you will have customers
who ask questions about how to use your
product you need to respond to that by
offering content in which you answer
their questions exciting brands don't
have a problem to get social media
engagement with their content they have
thousands of fans who love to talk about
the brand's Harley Davidson is a classic
example these brands need to keep on
posting amazing content that become
almost like collector items for their
fans finally vital brands are for the
greater benefit of mankind
Greenpeace World Wildlife Fund UNICEF
they have no problem in getting
engagement and discussions but they
should be very alert on what people are
talking about and try to find
influencers that can help them spread
their course so think about is when you
start putting your content marketing
strategy together it will guide you on
the type of content and campaigns you
should create and the types of calls to
action you should set social channel
strategy before you're going to decide
on the type of content you're going to
create it makes sense to agree on the
social media channels you are going to
use in the listening stage you have
learned on which channels your clients
hangout so now you're going to make sure
you are there as well you're going to
synchronize the branding the key
messages and the campaigns to grow your
followers on these channels you need to
make sure you understand the latest
features and trends on these social
channels it is also good to do
content gap analysis what type of
content do you already have for each
channel and where are the gaps so you
know what type of content you need to
create here is a useful template you can
use for this it shows you the channels
to structure the tone of voice for each
Channel and to desired action the gaps
will give you an indication of the work
you need to do to make sure you have a
coherent content marketing strategy
content marketing playbook so now you
are in a position to decide on the type
of content you're going to create here
is a list structured by the three types
of content we saw earlier link
conversion and authority content link
content and authority content can be
fairly similar its moral the promotion
site where they differ but the
conversion content needs to be organized
along the customer journey from
awareness to evaluation to purchase we
call this the marketing playbook
you need to create your own by selecting
the right content for the right stage
measuring content marketing efforts you
can measure the traffic you get through
your content you can measure the
engagement you get and you can measure
the sentiments whether you were
targeting consumers or businesses the
metrics are the same but the priorities
may differ today lead generation is seen
as the number one KPI when it comes to
measuring the success of your content
marketing closely followed by traffic
generation to your website these metrics
show how your content marketing efforts
are succeeding but you need to go a
level deeper to discover what specific
content campaigns channels and efforts
are most effective in driving value and
in the end whether you are in b2c or b2b
it comes down to measuring the ROI of
your content marketing how much money
did you earn from your content marketing
in relation to the cost you incurred in
creating and distributing it the things
that can improve your ROI or quality of
your leads sales wept
fake engagement SEO success and brand
exposure and remember improved ROI is
not just based on more sales
it can also be based on lowering costs
planning your content marketing strategy
planning your content marketing strategy
is very important there are so many
things you need to take into
consideration if you don't put some
structure into this you may lose control
it is best to create your content
marketing process guides in this guide
you specify how you create and manage
your content how you optimize and curate
how you listen and engage in
conversations and how you measure your
content marketing besides this there is
the tactical stuff like roles and
responsibilities what are the style and
writing guidelines and similar what are
the guidelines for posting and
publishing and make sure you communicate
a process guide to the relevant people
in your organization you may want to put
a training together to the people who
will work with this on a daily basis a
vital part of your process guide is the
content marketing calendar it's the
calendar that contains your content
production and publication schedule
there are many templates and tools for
this on the internet my favorite ones
are Trello comm and Google Calendar the
most important part of it is that it is
a collaborative tool so you can schedule
the calendar with your colleagues or
with your clients you can give people
viewing or editing access you can use
color codes for the different types of
content or for the different channels
becoming a content marketing company to
give you a framework on how to organize
your content marketing strategy in your
company you can look at the Content
Marketing Institute for business models
for content marketing they can be mapped
in a quadrant with strategic importance
on one axis and internal external focus
on the other you're a player when your
content marketing strategy is focused on
supporting teams within the organization
like your product marketing or marketing
communication teams
most companies start a content marketing
like this it's seen as a contributor
you're a performer when you're content
marketing is seen as a center of
excellence in your organization it has
an external focus where audience
segmentation is key it can be seen as a
support function to other parts in the
organization you're a processor when you
centralize certain content functions but
not the actual creation of it your
corporate team may create a content
campaigns with the corporate guidelines
where your local teams are responsible
for local content creation to execute a
campaign and your platform when you
approach a content marketing as a
strategic business within your business
often this is done on a corporate level
and this is separate from local content
marketing initiatives so you need to
understand where you are today and have
a vision of where you want to go so here
are the key takeaways from this lesson
content strategy is the management of
any tangible media written visual or
audible that you create and own content
marketing is about creating and
distributing valuable relevant and
consistent content to generate website
traffic and new leads the content
creation framework consists of linked
content conversion content and authority
content it puts your content in the
context of the customer journey a
customer persona is a semi-fictional
representation of your ideal customer
based on market research and real data
about your existing customers stories
are the currency of content marketing
and your story starts with your mission
and your editorial statements and
content marketing ROI is how much
revenue you came from your content
marketing in comparison to what you
spent on creating and distributing your
content
[Music]